bonsoir madonna - 30
le décompte est commencé dans 30 minutes
c'est à dire quand ce journal sera
terminé madonna se présentera sur
l'immense scène du parc de sceaux devant
cent mille mado maniaque qui ont craqué
pour la rijole moyennant la modique
somme de 150 francs événement musical de
l'année et succès assuré pour cette
américaine qui retrouve paris après
avoir fait chalouper les teenagers du
monde entier sur des rythmes qui font
désormais partie de la culture de notre
temps madonna à -29 en direct dans ce
journal
jean jacques dufour oui et bien depuis
le début de l'après midi des centaines
de milliers de personnes ont envahi le
parc de sceaux dessinés par le nôtre
évidemment ça ne se remarque plus
beaucoup que le parc de sceaux a été
dessiné par le nôtre c'est la première
fois sûrement qu'en france un concert
rassemble autant de monde
le public de madonna est jeune et tout à
l'heure nous avons fait un petit
micro-trottoir pour essayer de connaître
les motivations de ses fans
vous allez voir les motivations sont
extrêmement diverses
si vous venez d'où lee la 12e vous
habiller comme madonna
ouais pourquoi parce que j'aime bien on
a des gens compétents
monsieur world en fait j'espère qu'alain
nous n'allons vectis vraiment le sexisme
d'enfer l'écoutent pas tellement
laragnais comme celle de la bouche bien
sur scène je l'avoué je sais qu'elle
devient des contrats sur scène un show à
la romaine mademoiselle chico
interprétera 16 chansons échangera 16
fois de costumes 1
par chance on est alors plus que vous
vous n'avez pas la chance d'être ici au
parc de sceaux on a pris un extrait d'un
de ses clips et on va vous le donner en
avant-première 28 minutes avant le
concert de madonna
et
ans